see the problem is like with with all
this
the living by principles living in
principle life focusing on relationships
and kind of
thinking of this life as this perfect
thing kind of forgets the notion that
none of it you know makes any sense
right like the like it
it kind of implies that this is like a
video game and you want to get a high
score
as opposed to none of this even makes
sense
like why would he like what that
like like what does it even mean to die
it's gonna be over it's like everything
i do
all these productivity hacks all this
life all these efforts all this creative
efforts kind of assume it's going to go
on forever
there's a kind of uh sense of
immortality and i don't even know how
intellectually makes sense that it ends
uh of course gotta ask you in that
context what do you think is the
meaning of it all especially for
computer scientists i mean yeah there's
got to be some mathematical uh
yeah 27 or what's the what's the
douglas adams yeah or 40 40 42 okay 20
27 is a better number
i should read more sci-fi um you're on
to something with a 27.
i don't want to give away too much but
just trust me 27. invisible
yeah um so i mean
i don't know obviously right i mean i'm
just hoping
yeah i i don't know but but going back
to what you were saying about the sort
of the existentialist
or the sort of the more nihilist style
approach
the one thing that that there is are
intimations
right so there's these intimations to
human halves of somehow this feels
right and this feels wrong this feels
good this feels like
i'm doing i mean aligned with something
you know when i'm acting with courage to
save whatever right it's not
these intimations are a grounding
against arbitrariness
like one of the ideas i'm really
interested in is that uh
when you look at religion right so i'm
i'm interested in world religions for
for
my grandfather was a like a theologian
that studied and wrote all these books
i'm very interested in this type of
stuff
and there's this great book that's it's
it's not um specific to a particular
religion but it's karen armstrong wrote
this great book called the case for god
she's very interesting she was a
catholic nun who sort of left that
religion and is
but one of the smartest thinkers uh
in terms of like accessible theological
thinking that's not tied to any
particular religion
her whole argument is that the way to
understand religion you first of all
have to go way back pre-enlightenment
where all this was formed we got messed
up thinking about
religion post enlightenment right and
and um
these were operating systems for making
sense of intimations
the one thing we had were these
different informations of this field
like ah
and mystical experience and this feels
some there's something you feel when you
act in a certain way
and don't act in this other way and it
was like the scientists who were trying
to
study and understand the model of the
atom by just looking at
experiments and trying to understand
what's going on like the great religions
of the world were basically figuring out
how do we make sense of these
intimations and live in alignment with
them and build a life of meaning around
that
what were the tools they were using they
were using ritual they were using belief
they were using action
but all of it was like an os it was like
a liturgical model of the atom that
did it's hardcoded in so it's it did uh
through the evolutionary process
sometimes i mean they wouldn't have
called it that back then
or yeah i mean whether they said who
they didn't have that there's
pre-enlightenment
they just say this is here and and the
directive is to
to try to live in alignment with that
well then i want to ask who wrote the
original code
yeah so that's so one question yeah so
armstrong lays out this good argument
and where it gets really interesting is
that
that she emphasizes that all of this was
considered ineffable
right so the whole notion and this is
like rich in jewish tradition in
particular and also an islamic tradition
we can't comprehend and understand
what's going on here right
and so the best we can do to approximate
understanding and live in alignment as
we
like act as if this is true do these
rituals have these actions or whatever
post enlightenment a lot of that got
once we learned about enlightenment
we grew these suspicions around religion
that are very much of the modern era
right so like the
the karen armstrong like uh sam harris's
critique of religion makes no sense
right the the critiques based on well
this is you're making the ascent to
propositions that you think are true for
which you do not have evidence that they
are true
like that's an enlightenment thing right
this is not the context and this is
not the religion is the rutherford model
of the atom like it's not actually maybe
what
is underneath happening but this model
explains why your chemical equations
work and so this is like the way
religion was you you
there's a god we'll call it this this is
how it works we do this ritual we act in
this way it aligns with it
just like the model of the atom
predicted why you know n a and c
l is going to become salt this predicts
that you're going to feel and live in
alignment right it's like this beautiful
sophisticated theory which actually
matches how a lot of great theologians
have you know thought about it um but
then when you come forward in time yeah
maybe it's evolution i mean
this is like what peterson hints at
right like he's basically
he's not he doesn't like to get super
pinned down on this but i'm just it's
kind of seems where
he's he's almost like searching for the
words he focuses more on like jung and
other people but
uh i mean i know he's very union but but
that same type of analysis i think
roughly speaking like armstrong is sort
of a it's kind of like a petersonian
analysis but she's looking
more at the deep history of religion
than uh
but yeah he throws in the evolutionary
yeah and i wonder what holmen finds
i i wonder what the new home is if
religion dissipates
with the new home for these kinds of
natural inclinations are
uh yeah well there's technology whether
and if it's evolution i mean this is
francis collins book also he's like well
that's a religious that could be a very
religious notion i don't i think this
stuff is interesting i'm not a very
religious person but i'm
uh i'm thinking it's not a bad idea
maybe maybe what replaces honestly like
maybe what replaces religion is a return
to
religion but in this sort of more
sophisticated
i mean if you went back yeah i mean it's
the issue with like a lot of the
the recent critiques i think is it's a
it's a straw man critique in a
complicated way right because the
the whole way these the way this works i
mean the theologians if you're reading
paul tillich if you're reading
heschel if you're reading these people
they're thinking very sophisticatedly
about religion in terms of this it's
ineffable and we're just these things
and this is deep
it connects us to these things in a way
that puts life in the line man we can't
really explain what's going on because
we our brains can't handle it right
um for the average person though this
notion of live as if is kind of how
religions work
is live as if this is true it's like an
os
for getting in alignment with because we
through cultural evolution like you
behave in this way do these rich
live as if this is true um gives you
the what the goal you're looking for but
that's a complicated thing live as if
this is true because if you
especially if you're not a theologian to
say uh
yeah this is not true in an
enlightenment sense but i'm living as if
it kind of
takes the heat out of it but of course
it's what people are doing because you
know highly religious people still do
bad things where if you really were
you know there's absolutely a hell and
i'm definitely going to go to it if i do
this bad thing you would never have
you know no one would ever murder anyone
if they were uh evangelical christian
right so
so it's like what this is kind of a
tangent that i'm i'm
i'm on shaky ground here but it's
something i've been
interested off and on a lot well it's
fascinating i mean i think we're in some
sense searching for
because it is it does make for a good
operating system we're searching for a
good
live as if x is true and we're searching
for a new x
yeah and maybe artificial intelligence
will be
the very the new gods that we're so
desperately looking for or it'll just
spit out 42.
i thought it was 27. yeah that's as uh
as you know i've been a huge fan uh so
are a huge number of people
that i've spoken with so they've been
telling me i
absolutely have to talk to you this was
a huge honor this was really fun thanks
for wasting all this time with me yeah
no likewise i'm a long time fan so this
is a lot of fun
yeah thanks man
you